[Music]
in the past few years many republican
governors have signed legislation
targeting lgbtq people into law two
controversial bills are now law in
alabama a bill regulating what school
bathroom oklahoma students use a house
committee passed a bill focused on
pronouns and hundreds more of these
bills have been introduced in state
legislatures
more every year for the last three years
the laws are increasingly focused on
what sports teams transgender school
children can play on which bathroom they
can use and about the use of pronouns
but these bills are at the state level
if you look to the federal government
you'd hear a different message to
transgender students we're here to say
that's wrong and it's against the law
that's because the current federal
government believes gender identity
discrimination violates a 1972 federal
civil rights law so when it comes to the
rights of trans students conservative
states and the federal government are at
odds
but the enforcers of education policy
are a third level of government local
school boards and they are caught in
between with extraordinarily high stakes
i was thinking wow there's no way i'm
ever gonna vote yes for this
[Music]
gender affirmation
is suicide prevention
this coming year will be my seventh year
teaching in tennessee i'm seeing a lot
more depression a lot more anxiety i'm
seeing a lot a lot of suicidal ideation
which
the data bears out
one estimate says that 20 percent of
trans and non-binary youth will attempt
suicide
that's two times the rate of their
cisgendered peers
and other surveys on mental health and
trans youth find that they are more than
twice as likely as cisgender children to
experience bullying or to not attend
school because they didn't feel safe
i do have a transgender son that is 17
years old i live in murfreesboro
tennessee almost nowhere have more
anti-lgbtq bills been introduced this
year than in tennessee and at least two
anti-trans laws related to participation
in school sports and bathrooms have
already gone into effect
tennessee's bathroom law allows students
parents or teachers to sue schools if
they allow a transgender student in the
bathroom of their gender identity when
others are in there in our school the
rule is
trans kids either have to use the
restroom designated for their sex
assigned at birth or
they need to go find a single stall
gender neutral restroom and our campuses
were not built that way from one end of
the school to the other upstairs on this
end to downstairs on that the one time
that toby decided to just go ahead and
go into the mail
facilities they started chanting
they started beating on the stall door
you're asking a kid to fight through
dysphoria and to put themselves in
harm's way
in 2021 when the tennessee laws went
into effect most school boards adopted
it as policy
but not all of them
we are being asked to pass a policy
that goes along with state law yet is a
violation of civil rights
this is the metro nashville public
school board which governs the school
district of roughly 80 000 students
discussing whether or not to adopt the
state law that bans transgender athletes
from participating in girls sports in
public middle and high schools it is a
moral and ethical dilemma for for me as
a board member it was not something
that anyone on our board was willing to
make the motion to pass the focus has
just been wrong like how is this
something that we're put placing at the
feet of our children all those in favor
of deferring policy 4.301 raise your
hand okay unanimous we're in this place
now where we as a district have been
able to say there are
adults and people in charge in your life
who support you and care about you and
so the thought that our hand may be
forced
to implement these anti-trans policies
is very scary to me
but that decision is in a legal gray
zone
and it could have consequences
[Music]
school boards states and the federal
government all play a role in u.s
education policy but states in
particular have the most power over
public schools within their borders
that's because public education
in this country is traditionally funded
by property taxes which which are not
federal future but they're they're state
and local based school boards can set
their own policy but when states pass
laws related to public schools they are
obligated to adopt them if they don't
they risk funding funding funding
all the way that's a threat that holds
up hangs over our heads
pretty consistently and i mean we can't
function
without that funding typically the vast
majority of public school funding comes
from state and local governments but a
small portion does come from the federal
government mostly through programs
related to equity like for students with
disabilities and for students living in
poverty these kinds of resources augment
what's available from state and local
funds even though this slice is small
any school that receives federal
financial assistance is beholden to
title ix the 1972 civil rights law that
for 50 years has ensured that there is
no discrimination on the basis of sex
and for public schools the federal
agencies that enforce title ix
compliance are tied to whoever is in the
white house
and the past three administrations have
differed in their interpretation of
title ix the obama administration ruled
that it protects lgbtq students but the
trump administration reversed it and the
biden administration restored it again
that's why today in 2022 it's a
violation of federal civil rights law to
discriminate against lgbtq students in
public schools which could make a school
district liable to a federal
investigation
while some states who control most
school funding have passed laws contrary
to that so school districts have to
figure out what to do and so do the
families of trans students
i would say it it puts us in limbo
because
while we feel
heard and appreciated by maybe local
boards
the state is still saying
that
they're not welcome
so
what do you do it makes
makes all of us want to move
i get a little fuzzy about some of it
because it the federal law says that you
cannot do this
that
that supersedes
the state laws but yet they still do it
and then they cite governor lee's bills
as a reason to discriminate
in states like tennessee this legal
limbo could eventually be solved by a
lawsuit or federal civil rights
investigation that could overturn a
state law
there is already a federal lawsuit on
behalf of a trans teen boy in tennessee
suing to play on the boys golf team
and there's a federal lawsuit over
tennessee's bathroom law
but those won't necessarily change
things outside of tennessee
the institution with the power to do
that nationally and that could force
harmony with federal state and local
policy would be the supreme court
but if those rulings don't come out in
favor of trans students
the last line of defense will continue
to be those closest to them
teachers are going to be a big part of
saving kids lives depending on just how
willing they are to be supportive to be
affirming school has always been that
one place where we can hopefully find
somebody who
will
love us and value us for who we are
[Music]
is there anything else you'd like to add
just about
you know your personal experience i
could share one thing with you i came
across this last weekend was pride she
was very excited this is what she sees
right there she is and there's all these
people supporting the flag and and
they're you know giving her hearts and
fireworks and
i'm so thankful that this is how she
feels
i can't imagine that if
you know she did end up going to schools
or being
put into a situation where she wasn't
supported and celebrated that
this would not be the case i mean this
is clearly the world that you've created
for her yeah i mean i am not very good
at taking credit for things but i'm
pretty proud